c'est une annonce surprenante surtout
parce que depuis le début de la guerre
en ukraine la bulgarie et c'est vraiment
de ménager le grand frère russe et la
russie la russie de vladimir poutine et
se garde bien par exemple de livrer des
de l'armement à l'ukraine et il existe
bien sûr des divisions au sein de la
société bulgare au large mais aussi au
sein de la classe politique au sein du
gouvernement même qui est composée de
plusieurs partis qui ont des
orientations
géopolitique différentes disons donc le
parti socialiste qui est très pro russe
a fait partie de ce gouvernement il se
pose vraiment à ce que la bulgarie
livre des armes à l'ukraine est donc ce
débat est en cours en bulgarie surtout
que le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères dmitro coup les bars étaient
en visite à sofia la semaine dernière
justement pour essayer de convaincre ou
de demander à ces gouvernements bulgare
de une forme d' aide pour l'ukraine la
bulgarie une fois encore le gouvernement
bulgare a
refusé d'envoyer des armes elle a promis
d'envoyer des
des gilets pare-balles et des casques
voilà mais le premier ministre qui
répète coque est d'ailleurs en visite en
ukraine cette semaine a appelé à son
tour au que les bulgares fasse des dons
de leur salaire pour pouvoir financer
l'armement ukrainien donc c'est
surprenant mais ça pourrait être une
réponse justement assez à ces derniers
développements en bulgarie
oui alors on demande aux bulgares de
mettre la main à la poche mais déjà
quelles conséquences pourrait avoir
l'arrêt de ses livraisons de gaz russe
pour les consommateurs bulgares
alors le gaz naturel n'est pas
n'est pas vraiment important du mois ce
n'est pas la ressource fossile la plus
importante en bulgarie puisqu'on utilise
pour le chauffage central
qui est un système de chauffage hérité
du temps communistes bien sûr on a des
grosses centrales dans les grandes
villes qui chauffe de l'eau qui est
ensuite redistribué aux aux
contribuables mais
le gaz naturel n'est pas utilisé pour la
production d'électricité c'est plutôt
charbon c'est le nucléaire donc de ce
point de vue là il n'y aura pas vraiment
conséquences pour la bulgarie alors bien
sûr le gaz naturel influe fortement sur
les prix et l'inflation notamment qui
qui est presque de 10% cette année comme
comme un peu partout en europe et donc
là il pourrait y avoir vraiment des
conséquences très importantes pour pour
les bulgares notamment les personnes
âgées qui sont vraiment les plus
vulnérables avec avec des pensions de
retraite de l'ordre de 2 200 euros ou
moins pour les penseurs pour les
pensions minimums bien sûr il ya une
alternative aux 6es des livraisons de
gaz à diversification la diversification
des
de l'approvisionnement en gaz naturel on
parle de l'azerbaïdjan depuis un certain
moment mais il ya un problème
d'infrastructures là il n'y a pas
vraiment de moyens pour acheminer tout
ce gaz qui proviendraient de
l'azerbaïdjan via la turquie en bulgarie
et tous ses gazoducs qui devrait aider
la bulgarie juste avoir diversifié
c'est ses sources dans gaz naturel sont
en construction depuis dix ans
curieusement elles ne sont pas encore
prêtes le gouvernement avait promis
qu'il serait prêt d'ici juillet ça
semble pas ne pas encore être prêt
d'être d'être mise en
mise en service donc un gros point
d'interrogation là dessus aussi